this is a production of Cornell
University
hello everyone welcome to our first
entirely zoom seminar of the plant
biology seminar series it's a pleasure
to introduce Adam Boyko and Adams an
associate professor in our vet school in
the biomedical sciences department he
earned his Bachelor of Science degrees
in both computer science and ecology
ecology and evolution at the University
of Illinois urbana-champaign then he
earned just then he earned a MS in
computer science at Purdue University
and a PhD in biology at Purdue he did a
postdoc at Cornell with Carlos
Bustamante and moved with Carlos to
Stanford and then he returned to Cornell
as an assistant professor in 2011 Adams
lab uses dogs as a model of genetic
disease and evolutionary genetics and I
invited him to our seminar in part
because many of us are very interested
in genomics and the kinds of things he's
doing and also I invited him as our
career-related seminar for the semester
because he can give us a really
interesting perspective on both being in
academia and industry so Adam and his
brother Ryan founded embarked at dog
engine genomics company it's I mean if
you can correct me later but it's sort
of like 23andme but for dogs and Adams
the chief scientific officer and what's
really cool is that they use some of
this DNA with the owner's permission for
their research Adam we're really excited
to hear your seminar thanks for talking
for us today
Thanks thanks I'm really happy to be
here virtually or however we want to
want to say that it is the I will say
the coolest thing about starting embark
was that if you guys tuned in to
jeopardy on April 1st we were the
question of embark
which is kind of like 23andme does this
for dogs and the person got it right so
so embark was on Jeopardy so I think we
can all closed up shop now and be happy
but anyway I'm very happy to be here my
you know my background is in biology and
computer science I've always been
interested in understanding the
evolution of biological diversity my PhD
work was in Heliconius butterflies and
trying to understand how you evolved
learning patterns and I started my
postdoc you know working with human
genomic data sets and looking at the
structure of genetic variation in people
and the amount of it that's due to
neutral versus deleterious mutations and
I and I quickly transitioned into dogs
sort of by chance my my PII Carlos
Bustamante had a collaboration going
with some eminent canine researchers at
NIH and UCLA I'm looking at the
diversity of dogs and the genetics that
underlie it and dogs are a really great
model they've got you know of course the
plant world is full of tons of diversity
but in the mammal world dogs have the
largest range of variation and body size
of any species and and they also vary in
tons of other ways and because we've
selectively bred dogs to have different
behaviors and traits and fill different
roles it leads to in many cases extreme
behaviors being caused by just one or a
handful of mutations so for instance a
Kandra dysplasia which is lived warf ism
so you see that in beagles and corgis
and stuff that that's the same mutation
in all of those breeds it's just it's
just one mutation brachycephaly there's
a few mutations that cause it but it's
usually in any breed there's one
mutation that leads to the shorts now
phenotype and even things like body size
where there clearly are several genes
that are doing it the the genetic
underpinnings of it is a lot simpler
than what we would see and let's say
humans or most randomly breeding
populations and so you know one of the
first projects my lab did here at
Cornell was genotyping dogs from you
know doing an expanded cam app where we
looked at 158 different breeds and and
so if you genotype about ten dogs from
each of these so this is this is less
than 2,000 samples that we looked at you
very quickly can identify 18 different
genes that are associated with body size
p-values I'm for those of you who are
unfamiliar this is a Manhattan plot so
this is how geneticists do
Association studies and the goal here is
these are the log at the p-values so
this is kind of like the skyline of
Manhattan and the taller the skyscrapers
are more significant that Lukas is and
and so we see all of these jeans that
you know make sense you know insulin
growth factor one being being the
largest one here for for causing the
body size differences that we see in
dogs and if you were to do a comparative
study in people you know to us study
people the p-values are much lower it
takes much larger sample size so it
wasn't until we had like a thousand
people that we had you know heights for
and genetic data for that we started to
see the first genes and some of these
genes are the same like HMG a2 and and
as a consequence we can actually predict
from the genetics the adult expected
body size of a dog very accurately we
can explain easily eighty-five percent
of the variation just looking at two
dozen genes whereas in people you'd have
to look at hundreds and hundreds of
genes and you're only going to explain
about twenty to thirty percent of the
variation you know from that so it
wasn't just interested in course to
trade mapping so you know my background
is how natural populations evolved and
and a neat thing about dogs actually is
that most of the dogs in the world are
not purebred dogs even though most of
the research in dogs is done in purebred
dogs and in fact most of the dogs in the
world aren't even mixed breed dogs which
descend from purebred dogs but then have
been you know crossing with each other
most of the time of their own accord but
we also have designer breeds
deliberately done most of the dogs in
the world are what we would call free
ranging pre breeding dogs or village
dogs and so there's about a billion dogs
in the world and easily 60 or 70% of
them fall into this category and and
this is kind of how dogs initially
evolved right so you you know dogs
descended from gray wolves and and when
they descended from gray wolves they
didn't turn into poodles they they were
village dogs so basically you know the
lead theory is that they domesticated
themselves so wolves and human hunting
communities were we're going after the
same large prey and if there were
climatic changes or hunting humans got
better at hunting or or otherwise there
were hunting pressures and
it started you know some both
populations do better if they could
scavenge from the from the humans and in
order to do that you need to tolerate
the presence of humans you need to have
all this sort of tameness this ability
to read human cues so you know whether
or not the human is a threat to you and
then other things that go along with
scavenging like smaller body size so
you're less threatening and you don't
need as much provisioning and and be in
being able to reproduce multiple times a
year and so eventually once you start to
go down that path you're not going to go
back to being an obligate hunter of
large prey anymore and so it sort of set
the stage for this one small group of
wolves to expand out into dogs and so
now we have a million wolves in the
world and a billion dogs in the world so
it's a highly successful strategy and so
yeah most of the dogs in the world are
still indigenous village dogs although
once the tameness had evolved you could
start breeding these dogs you could
start selectively provisioning or
selectively mating a certain dogs and
this is this is how breeding typically
had been done so thousands of years ago
we had sled dogs we had sighthounds we
had Molosser type you know Guardian dogs
and then much more recently especially
during the Victorian era we've started
these closed purebred registry
populations and that really changes the
dynamics of the dogs sort of accelerates
drift and selection in those lines makes
them clearly genetically delineate it
but it's very different than how
traditionally breeding has been done
where you're where you're trying to
achieve a certain working ability
generally and and you're willing to
cross in and out in order to achieve the
consequence and the genome is
predictable so if you look at a Labrador
and you do a full genome sequence in the
Labrador you're gonna see there are many
genomic segments that are identical by
descent some of them quite large this is
not an atypical lab most labs are about
to have 20% of their genome in bred or
so this lab has all of chromosome 23 in
bred and if you compare that to a
village dog the IBD sexes are much much
smaller so you know even though
superficially
you might not always be able to tell us
that village dog is that you-know-what
but genetically they're they're very
different and this gives you information
that you don't get from here bred dogs
right so one of the questions about dogs
is where do they come from and you know
people have looked at many different
areas and there were theories that you
know they came from Eastern East Asia
they came from the Middle East they came
from Europe and and a lot of these
studies have been biased because the
genetic analysis was done primarily in
purebred dogs and you know like try and
understand human origins by looking at
European royal families you're not
really going to capture the full amount
of genetic diversity only some of the
diversity that's and the natural dog
populations actually made it into these
various purebred lines and so in fact by
going around for the village dog project
and sampling these dogs we could look at
patterns like linkage disequilibrium and
see where what the rate of decay was in
the different populations and we clearly
got a very different picture than what
other groups had been seeing where it
looks like Central Asia has this clear
signature of a center of diversity and
so so we think that that makes the most
sense as as origin for domestic dogs in
my lab we also have tried mapping other
traits of interest so one of the things
we looked at was how much each breed of
dog sheds and and in fact if you can
characterize that you can actually do a
genetic mapping project and we found a
new locus that that contributes to
shedding behavior so so we've always
known so we've known since the candy bat
project of this are spawned in locus on
chromosome 13 that gives kind of the
wiry hair like coat for poodles that's
low shedding but there's the secondary
locus this Molina Courtin receptor on
chromosome one and so for dogs that
don't have the poodle coat if you've got
the the wolf variant of this MC 5 RR
allele you're going to be high shedding
whereas if you have the boxer very
you're going to be low shipping and so
that's that's also a trait that you know
a lot of people might be interested in
we not only looked at things that you
know we think have been on
selection in dogs but because my lab was
generating a lot of dog DNA data so the
you know these studies here at based on
4,000 dogs that was the largest genetic
analysis of dogs at the time we could go
back and most of the most of the dogs
that weren't village dogs that got
collected were collected at the bio Bank
at the Cornell vet school and so they
had veterinary records attached to them
and so one of the things many dogs that
go into the Cornell vet school get are
our blood panels rat CBC's and blood
chemistry panels and so we could go back
and we could look at the data from those
and see if anything associated with the
genetics of the dog and one of the clear
associations we got so this is a zoom in
on a Manhattan plot at the locus on
chromosome 13 where we found this
significant association of alt so
alanine aminotransferase
this is signal it's a signal of liver
damage and so you if you have high
values of it it means that your liver is
not functioning the way that it should
and it's centered right over this gene
GPT which actually encodes the
transferring so it makes a lot of sense
that if there is going to be an
association it's gonna be there so
there's some variant here likely
associated with this GPT gene that leads
to very different values of alt when
healthy dogs are tested and so the
reference range you know it's published
that veterinarians use it's you know
somewhere around you know 12 to 99 is
considered healthy and if you look the
average values in healthy dogs generally
fall within that but they're different
depending on whether it's the wild-type
GG or whether it's homozygous for this
mutation and petyr's I guess is
intermediate for it and and the reason
that's relevant is if the dog actually
does have liver disease so then we went
back to dogs that have been diagnosed
with liver disease and then you look and
you see what the alt values are well
sure enough they're all elevated as you
would expect but the dogs that are AAA
don't elevate nearly as much as the
other dogs do it in fact you know a half
of them or more are still in the normal
range even though the mean is up to 181
because
really really drive that so you you're
gonna miss the diagnosis if you're
relying on this and you don't understand
the interaction with genetics so it's
one of these things where reference
ranges are published for species in
veterinary world or at best for
populations but really they should be
considered on an individual level and if
we can if we can get the genetic data
that we can more accurately predict what
an individual's healthy range is we can
probably do much better in the clinic so
we've looked at patterns of selection
across all the dog populations in my lab
and and we can see that there's many
regions of the genome that we can
associate now with selection for body
size body shape skull morphology there's
other regions of the genome that we
associate with fur traits such as
shedding or wire coat or coat color we
see signals of positive selection on the
dog MHC region the dog leukocyte antigen
area and chromosome 12 but we also see
lots of regions of the genome that have
signatures of selection that we have not
associated with the phenotype yet and so
this has led to you know we have
low-hanging fruit of the dog genome we
just have to ask the right questions to
figure out you know what's driving
selection which lines misses being
driven and and and you know how do these
selected traits evolve so you know I
would say that dog geneticists have made
a lot of progress understanding but we
would call me alien disease there's over
250 diseases that we know the cause of
mutation for in dogs
so other than mice and human I think we
know more about madelia disease of dogs
than any other species we certainly know
a lot about the genes that control major
morphological traits but we don't know
as much about the genetics of complex
disease we don't know the genes that go
into hip dysplasia or most of the genes
involved in cancer or being able to
predict the risk and being able to you
know breed dogs that are less at risk
music genetic testing we we haven't
found too many genes involved in
behavior I mean the one exception that
sort of proves the rule is we is there
locus for canine compulsive disorder I
mean actually falls in the same gene
that's been associated with human
obsessive compulsive disorder so we
think it's the same gene we just can't
talk to the dogs to know if they're
obsessing or not so we call it something
else but for other behaviors that we've
sort of positively selected for like
prey drives and things like that we
haven't yet made the associations so so
it's more more complicated there to do
it we probably don't have the right you
know sample sizes that we need to do
this and we've also made a little more
progress understanding how genetics and
longevity are related we know that large
dogs die sooner but beyond that we don't
know exactly why we don't know if it's
specific genes that are causing this if
there's way to ways to breed big dogs to
live longer using other genes you know
what cats live longer than dogs like
there's there's lots of stuff that we
don't understand and dogs because they
have such a range of size variation and
because that's associated with a
two-fold variation and expected
longevity they're a really nice model
for trying to understand how genetics
and healthy aging interact and so
basically the limiting factor here is
that large scale studies are needed
right so the 4,000 dogs that my lab
looked at are not going to be enough to
tackle these questions we know from
human genetics that is going to take
many many more samples probably hundreds
of thousands in order to do something
like this so I was at the stage of my
research where okay well we've now
looked at the genetics of nearly 5,000
samples that we've gotten a bio Bank
we've made some cool discoveries the bio
bank has 20,000 samples so you know if
we could get funding to look at more of
them you know that would be great I you
know I've already kind of tapped out at
my age funding we got National
Geographic funding like where do I go to
next to do this kind of big data thing
how am I ever gonna get hundreds of
thousands of samples so that I can study
cancer and I can study behavior and we
can make progress on allergies and and
all sorts of stuff that you know people
are really interested in so at the same
time I'm thinking these things of course
you know we've been recruiting dogs in
the community to be involved in studies
we've got some you know press
buzz from that we get lots of people ask
me can my dog take part in your research
studies and can you tell me you know
what my dog is and why he is the way
that he is and so it's sort of you know
got this idea that if we could do
genetic testing the right way we could
help people understand their dogs better
give them the information that they
would need to you know to understand
what lies down the road what risk
factors should this dog bred who should
it be bred to you know things like that
and then we would get all of this data
back that we could use to actually build
really large research studies if if
something like this was popular if there
was enough demand for and so the idea is
personalized genetics for dogs so we
would want to you know for the same
things that you do for humans into
23andme for instance we want to predict
disease predispositions we want to
identify relatives in the ancestry
people want to participate in citizen
science research and some sort of
explanation of you know why do I have
red hair or why do I sneeze when I walk
out of a movie theater things like that
and so and the neat thing is there's
four million Americans born every year
and there's 8 million dogs that are born
in America every year so there's this
huge potential for for research study if
you know if this if this takes off and
so so that was the idea for starting and
Mark and so my brother who had been
participating in the village dog project
traveling around the world off and on
over you know over the course of a
decade as he as he was graduating from
Yale you know we talked it over and so
he he decided yeah we'll take the plunge
and so he's CEO and I'm the Science Guy
for for the company there and so we so
the idea is we use the same sorts of
Illumina genotyping arrays that
researchers use although we add in
specific markers for specific analyses
but but ideally it's this discovery
platform where you're looking at over
200,000 markers and so it gives you a
lot more data than any other
test of the market which makes it you
know more accurate for doing lots of
different stuff and and if we can keep
customers engaged it will fuel discovery
and so over 90 percent of the people who
do embark have their dogs updating for
participating in research most of them
have filled out surveys about their dog
so we have this information about the
dog's health or temperament or
environment and then we can update as
new discoveries are made what you know
whether the dog is predisposed for
something or something like that so you
know my dog at home is penny so penny we
got from a shelter up in Rochester she
was labeled a Basenji terrier mix which
I thought would was odd and sure enough
when we actually genetically analyzed
penny we saw that well she was a terrier
mix but she had a lot of other stuff
that wasn't missing gee that explained
why she had a crooked tail and all that
other stuff and so you know with n mark
you've got research health breed traits
and relatives as possible you know areas
that you get results for so that so for
the health Penny's clear of the genetic
conditions that we tested for at the
time we did the test we've expanded the
chip now we've got more and more stuff
you get a family tree which is sort of
an estimation of you know how we think
the breed breeds got into her you know
of course you don't you know have a
crystal ball you can't always get the
family tree hundred-percent a cure but
you at least know like is the Jack
Russell Terrier on both halves of the
family tree one half and things like
that we can look at the the various coat
color genes and other you know traits
that we can match and so so we can look
specifically at the e locus which
variant does she carry out the B locus
what very tight security at the D locus
with fur industry and we can combine all
of these you know to help the user see
what what should the coat pattern of
your dog look like it so in Penny's case
and she's tipped sable and so sure
enough yes so she's got you know she's
got the white underbelly and just in the
brown back and black on the tail in
years and and snout and then what I
thought was really cool is we got to see
relatives and so you know after about a
year or two we actually had a cousin of
penny that wound up testing with us and
we had no idea
that these dogs were related these dyes
are adopted a year apart but Dharma
Penny's cousin also lives in the Ithaca
area and so we've actually been able to
go out and visit Dharma and it's
actually pretty incredible how similar
they are it's like the same chassis but
different paint job and a lot of the
behaviors are very very similar between
Penny and Dharma and these and they have
some health issues like they both have
had lots of teeth removed for enamel
hypoplasia so we think there's a genetic
component to that and so you know most
most people don't know their dogs family
medical history so it is kind of cool if
you if when you start seeing that
there's relatives of your dog and
reaching out to them penny is not inbred
she's out bred and we're not breeding
her so it's less than issue but we also
can look at dogs so this is a I believe
a Doberman Pinscher you know that we
looked at and we can we can calculate
the inbreeding not from the pedigree of
the Doberman which only goes back a
certain number of generations and it's
just an estimate anyway
we actually look across the genome like
we did for those whole genome sequence
dogs could be any of the lecture and we
can see which parts of the genome are
identical by scent and total that out to
get an ingredient coefficient and so
that's another thing that you get to
learn about your dog and then you know
finally to close the loop you can also
take these surveys and assessments for
your dog and so we're asking customers
things like have allergies are they food
allergies or seasonal allergies or you
know things like that and with the idea
that we're building this database that's
gonna drive discovery in the future and
make diente testing even more valuable
of dogs and hopefully provide avenues
for therapeutics for reducing the
prevalence in breed dogs and for
translational you know research where
you have to see as they're common in
dogs and easier to study in dogs and
they aren't people so yeah that compares
on 23andme has been made several times
okay 23 Mead came around about nine
years before embarq started they
launched their first genetic test in
2007 and just about three years later
they got their first scientific
publications this is humans were testing
themselves to learn more about their
ancestry to learn more about their
health predispositions and then they
were filling out very detailed surveys
about themselves
so the scientists could see if they
could make any more associations and and
so so the first paper that 23 me the
first associations they made were
freckling so this is the BNC to Jean so
this wasn't known to be involved in
pigmentation at the time but it was
clear that it explained a certain
fraction of freckling in the in the
customer database photic sneeze reflex
so this means if you are in a dark room
and then you walk out the bright
sunlight do you do you have this urge to
sneeze and so this is m2 gene is
interesting because it's actually been
implicated now for light induced
epilepsy so so we think that the
mutation that's driving this association
is just a subclinical kind of epileptic
type thing may be going on so it's kind
of an interesting model now that we we
wouldn't have known about without that
sort of testing and and then the third
trait that they published was asparagus
and Sonia so this is whether or not
after you eat asparagus you report that
your urine smells so again these were
very detailed surveys that people were
filling out and and as it turns out this
trade map significantly to an olfactory
receptor so a lot of scientists thought
it was a metabolic thing some people
broke down asparagus different ways that
other people did but it's actually it's
an olfactory receptor so everybody
breaks down asparagus the same way just
some people smell the metabolites and
some people don't and people don't
typically smell other people's pee so
that's why so these seem like kind of
you know fun but not really like
important for health sorts of traits and
that's may be true but down the line
they definitely did you know make
significant contributions as their
database increased in size and and they
could ask you know more and more
health-related questions and they've
identified novel risk factors for things
like asthma they did a lot with
Parkinson's research
osteoporosis tons of major medical
conditions that honestly it would have
been difficult if not impossible to get
the same sample sizes it certainly would
cost a lot of government funding or
something in order to do that and so
really contributed to research as well
as enabled research that just wouldn't
have
done otherwise almost certainly so when
you have large datasets you can ask all
sorts of questions and you can get
really cool findings about there's
genetic associations for educational
attainment age of reproduction mosquito
attractiveness and symptoms you know
things like that
so that they are really medical but
they're you know if you're interested in
that kind of stuff they are you know
really interesting things to look at so
at the end of are the first traits and
the first publication we get was a
little bit of a surprise it was just one
of those questions that we asked and we
saw this you know clear association
signal for it was blue eyes so what
color are your dog's eye is that
something people can answer really
easily we run a gene Watts analysis of
that we saw the association that we
expected on chromosome 10 at the merle
locus so this is the funky coat that
some Australian Shepherds and other dogs
can have and that can lead to blue eyes
but we started an even stronger
association on chromosome 18 which was
not previously identified as having to
do with pigmentation at all and is and
it was driving the blue eye phenotype
that you see in some Siberian Huskies
and related breeds and sure enough we
looked at the array data we could see
that there is a conserved haplotype in
many of the Siberian Huskies that have
it although we saw this sub region that
also met all of the dogs that were
homozygous had a heterozygous gene
called so that's not expected and so
that's that's an indication that there's
likely a structural variant going on
there which is making the genotyping
weird and so sure enough when we look at
whole genome sequence data that's been
publicly deposited we can see that
Siberian Huskies show a duplication
across the region spanning those markers
we could actually do a breakpoint
analysis and identify you know
specifically where this duplication it's
a tandem duplication
it's about 99 kilobases long and and we
could ask okay so was it the snip
Association or is it really this
duplication that's driving the phenotype
and so what's great is we have the
contact information for everybody that
tested with that mark and so so we said
okay well that was our discovery panel
was everybody who answered that that
survey on the website now everybody
didn't answer the survey on the website
let's email them and ask them what color
their dog's eyes are and so we have this
validation panel that that that's in
place and so we could get another 2700
dogs you know it's just in a matter of
the weekend filling this out and then we
can look at me and say oh yeah so that
snip is still associated in their
validation set you know clearly 10 to
the minus 120 power but the duplication
is much much more associated with it and
so that's that's likely what's driving
the phenotype and I think this is
probably the most significant p-value in
canine genetics so far and it was the
biggest mapping study in Dodge Nexus
6,000 you know dogs so so if I haven't
driven home the point of big data being
important it is and so looking at the
things that we want to look at we
unfortunately the database has been
growing so if you look at the number of
dogs that we've got genome data for
where the owners have consented for
scientific research we see that it keeps
growing year after year and we're up to
about a quarter million you know right
now and so the kinds of studies were
able to start undertaking you know are a
lot more useful and and the reason why
it's growing is because you know we've
got you know high customer satisfaction
so they like what they're saying so I
think we're four point seven stars on
Amazon or something like that which is
not only higher than other dog DNA tests
but it's also higher than I think any
other genetic test that's out there and
it's mostly been driven by people
wanting to know what makes their dog is
so most of the customers are mixed breed
dog owners but we do have a lot of
purebred dogs and breeders and they know
what breed their dog is but they're
doing it for the for the health testing
or relative finding your inbreeding
analysis or stuff like that and then
that that tiny little sliver there is
primarily village dogs and so you know
one of the ideas of starting the company
is I mean we could probably get a lot
more data if people just sent us their
dogs DNA and then if we had to like
travel out into like the remote
rainforests we're trying to get dogs and
and so we only have a sliver of village
dogs that are going in there but that's
still over 3,000 dogs so it's actually
you know five times more
any other village drug analysis that
we've you know been able to do we can
and many of these dogs are coming from
places that would not have been feasible
you know or cheap for us to go to into
sample so that's been that's been really
nice to so like to put it in perspective
you know it took my lab you know
basically five years to get the funding
and to do the analysis to get you know
five thousand dogs analyzed and on cyber
monday this just last year in one day we
had 10,000 kids that result so we got
twice as much data so it's a very
effective way to get you know large
amounts of data what's interesting is
there although there's high customer
satisfaction you do have the occasional
customer that's like very very
unsatisfied and to have to walk through
you know the genetics you know so we had
one customer whose dog came back as half
golden retriever in half soft coated we
and they're like well this is impossible
my dog is black so there's no way that a
gold dog and an apricot dog they're
gonna cross to make a black dog but the
great thing is we're already testing all
the like health and trait things and so
you can walk through the genetics and
you can be like well actually golden
retrievers are golden you know because
of their recessive at the e locus and
soft coded we tins are gold our apricot
because they're recessive
they've got recessive yellow but that's
the K locus and so then when you cross
them you get two heterozygotes and so
it's not surprising that you have a
black dog so you have to do a lot of
customer service in order to sort of
explain these things here's the customer
that that was complaining because they
knew their dogs results had to be wrong
their dog clearly was a breed you know
that was not in there and look at the
results like well I mean I don't know it
looks reasonable like how well what
breed is supposed to be in there like
with it like my parent was a whippet or
something like that would be you know it
should have come up on that on the trait
how do you know the dog isn't that well
I don't know who the parents are but
like if you look at the dog it's got the
whip its smile it has to be part with it
and so you know like you know a lot of
stuff is uh you have to walk people
through and get them to understand it
and and some people really have
unreasonable expectations you know so
they they go to a shelter they adopt a
dog
like a Border Collie of course the
shelter tells them it's a border collie
but genetically it's not a border collie
just for superficially resembles one and
so you have lots of you know lots of
hand-holding that that has to go on but
overall people are really pleased to
actually know what's in their dog
because it helps you help them kind of
understand where the dogs coming from or
maybe encourages them to do different
stuff from from a vet perspective though
one of the neat things and one of the
products I've been working on most
recently is the question of is genetic
testing actually worth it for mixed
breed dogs so all these people I just
want to know what breeds are in their
dog is it actually worth it can we test
for stuff that's relevant to enough dogs
to really justify the idea of you should
do genetic testing for that and you know
of course obviously like conflict of
interest you know like I have a DNA
testing company so I'm gonna be biased
right but but if we actually look at the
numbers here you know so we've got
several genetic conditions that are at
reasonably high frequency so none of
these are common right these are all
like bad diseases so they're not going
to be at high frequency but they're
still you know 1% frequency you know or
higher the so these are the allele
frequencies underlying so PRA is a form
of blindness and there's a couple
different kinds of PRA that are in dogs
and they're generally in certain breeds
of dogs and not in other breeds of dogs
huu is hyper Yoriko CS as bladder stones
so if you if you're predisposed to that
all Dalmatians are predisposed to that
if you've got that predisposition if you
fed a special painful stones and it
could take a while to diagnose sometimes
and cost a lot of money
CEA is another form of blindness common
in collies and related breeds AIC is
exercising these to collapse exes is a
skin disorder so all these things are
recessive traits and so if you look
they're there at a certain frequency and
mixed breed dogs generally they're at a
slightly lower frequency and purebred
dogs because breeders have tests and
they know what lines carry which and so
they can try to reduce the frequency
within the breeds in a way that you know
mixed breed dog breeding doesn't really
have that ability unless you're testing
for everything and actually trying
to to breed healthy mixes which
generally somehow makes pretty dogs made
and then village dogs have the lowest
frequency so these are all things that
are under selection right there they're
they're common in a lot of breeds that
so they they are ancient mutations that
are in a lot of lines but they've gotten
a much lower frequency due to natural
selection village dogs that isn't there
for pure Brits and mixed breed dogs um
even though the mixed breed dogs tend to
carry a slightly higher frequency than
the purebred to do they're less at risk
because they're more Outbrain in general
than purebred dogs you can't have inbred
mixed breed dogs but but on average
they're more Outbrain so overall the
at-risk frequency if you've got a mixed
breed dog at home for these tends to be
quite low in fact if you if you sum up
all of these oh and so I'm gonna say
there's one more disorder that we test
for which is sod one so this is this is
degenerative myelopathy which is like
canine ALS and this is also recessive
but it's it's late onset and it's very
incompletely penetrant so it seems like
it's only predictive in certain breeds
and not in other breeds and so it's not
really clear that that's an actionable
test right now at least for mixed breed
dog owners so so we're gonna ignore that
test for now and we're gonna say well
just look at the actionable recessive
disease test that you can do only about
1% of mixed-breed dogs I see at risk for
those so only 1% of dogs if you're not
planning and breeding them is this going
to be useful information but in fact
there's also MDR one so multi-drug
resistance and so this is a drug
sensitivity not just to like one driver
looks like whole classes of drugs
chocolate like different kind of food
things you know it's the it's the body's
ability to kind of cleanse different
toxins out and so and so this is a very
relevant it's not really a disease and
it's additive so even if you have one
copy that leads to some sensitivity and
you want to know if you have two copies
that leads to lots of sensitivity and so
so just adding that trait in there
suddenly we've got 3% of mixed-breed
dogs that are getting an actionable
result and then recently there was this
publication about intervertebral disc
disease and dogs and so this tends to
happen to like
long dogs lowriders and there's actually
a mutation separate from the chromosome
18 mutation which gives you that
phenotype but without predisposing for
for i vdd there's a chromosome 12
mutation so it's a it's a retro gene
it's the same retro dream that causes
the short limbs and basset hounds and
dachshunds but it's in a different
chromosomal location and it leads to
brittle discs and so much increased
likelihood of suffering from IV DD and
so they estimated that that three and a
half percent of all dogs get IBD and
it's essentially only dogs that carry
one or two copies of this so there's a
50 fold risk increase if your dog has
one or more copies of this seized and so
suddenly if that if that holds true for
mixed free dogs or they only look to
purebred dogs but if that holds true for
mixed breed dogs then suddenly you've
got 17 percent of mixed breed dogs
because again this isn't a recessive
disorder this is a dominant disorder are
gonna get an actionable result if your
dog is at risk for this you don't want
him jumping up you want to get ramps for
the stairs you want to give him
different supplements because it's a
very expensive and painful disease to
treat so we of course designed our
arraign designed to test so that we
could see whether or not a dog carried
this variant and we also could survey
owners and so we could ask owners you
know of all we asked them several
questions and one of them I BDD was one
of the disease's we asked about and then
we also asked whether they did any
changes to their dogs routine after they
got their genetic results so even if
their dog hasn't been diagnosed with IBD
if they see that it's at risk is there
you know did they do any of these things
that that would help mitigate that risk
and so we could you know very quickly
turn around a survey with 782
respondents and we could calculate that
dogs that had one or two copies of this
sort of were forty three times more
likely to have gotten diagnosed with it
and over half the dogs that hadn't been
diagnosed with it had changed their care
routine and so of course as we follow
these dogs through time it'll be
interesting to see whether the dogs had
changed their care routine before
diagnosis or more success
let's taping off the diagnosis or not or
which interventions you know made sense
but it definitely seems like now you
know about 1/6 of all mixed breed dogs
can get an actionable result and of
course this keeps growing as more and
more disparities remain so the other
area that my lab and then mark has been
interested in has been in breeding
because we see very large differences in
average inbreeding when we look at
different breeds of dogs so Dobermans
are very in bred beagles are much more
out bred when we look at data for mixed
breed dogs and purebred dogs from other
published from from other you know
sources like veterinary records that
don't have genetic data associated with
them we see that of course there's a
body size effect big dogs don't live as
long but for a given body size mixed
breed dogs seem to live a bit longer
than purebred dogs do by about a year or
so now that we have a large amount of
genetic data of course you know most of
the embark'd augs are young people tend
to get the test right after their dog
they got their dog or they heard about
embark but we have had you know
fortunately or unfortunately any fear
scientists there's some dogs a fair
number of dogs that have passed away and
so we can look at that longevity data
and ask ourselves whether or not it
seems to be associated with inbreeding
and so about a thousand dogs now with
with complete longevity data and we can
see that you know whether they're dogs
spayed or neutered has an effect
obviously weight has an effect but
coefficient of inbreeding also has an
effect and so you know you you lose you
know you know easily you know two years
of life if you go from 0% inbreeding to
50% inbreeding and in fact that pattern
holds both for purebred dogs and mixed
breed dogs so it looks like the age
curves are basically identical for the
two and it's just most mixed breed dogs
are you know over here completely
outbreak and only a few of them are
inbred whereas with purebred dogs is
much more evenly distributed and so if
we look within a breed you know so we've
had a lot of Dobermans that have been
tested we have you know clearly the the
Dobermans that were the most inbred
had shorter lifespans than that
that we're the most outbred and again if
we look at even larger datasets of
pedigree data we can see that the most
inbred golden retrievers have shorter
lifespans in the most outbreak girl
nurture so there seems to be a longevity
effect for inbreeding and beyond that we
actually collaborated with Morris Animal
Foundation czar that's running a golden
retriever lifetime study we did a
genetic analysis of about a hundred of
their female golden retrievers that had
been bred and and we could see even with
that small sample size there's clearly
this affected the more inbred females
had smaller litter sizes so there's lots
of lots of evidence to suggest that
we've got inbreeding depression in dog
populations today and in fact you know
so so we've got twenty percent of
purebred dogs can be at risk for
something and so it's important to do
genetic testing for that but it's also
the case that if you were to to do your
breeding so that you move more of the
dogs from you know the high inbred side
to the lower inbred side you're also
going to improve the health of dogs by
at least that order of magnitude and so
for for breeders we now have a
matchmaker tool where you can go through
and you can see dogs of the opposite sex
and you can see what would the expected
percent inbreeding be if that dog was
bred to your dog and you can see where
it falls on the you know on the line and
and you know hopefully you can try to
prefer more out cross dogs and more then
more light bred dogs through that sort
of thing so you know that's pretty much
what I what I came here for obviously
we're doing more genetic research into
health conditions now that we have this
you know really big database we are
recruiting for certain studies like
dilated cardiomyopathy tricuspid
dipthong dysplasia wobbler disease so so
we are trying to now leverage this big
data set to make the health discoveries
and go from there so hopefully next year
I'm gonna give this talk we'll have some
really cool stuff like that right now
we've got a lot of cool trait analyses
and associations and stuff but yeah so
in conclusion we do see recessive
disease in mixed breed dogs and so
and we seek Mendelian disease with IVD D
and so genetic testing for health
actually seems like it makes sense for a
lot of mixed breed dogs but beyond that
of course testing for these has always
been valuable for for purebred dog
breeders but but actually looking at COI
is gonna be just as valuable and so
getting the tools out there so that it
can use genetics to breed outbreak dogs
is is gonna help really make dogs
healthier and then you know beyond that
just if you can if you can do the
genetic testing in a way that it's done
in a research type platform dense
genotyping or sequencing platform so
that data can then be useful to drive
association and discovery there's lots
of opportunities you know for genetic
improvement of dogs and for getting new
genetic models for you know traits and
diseases so with that I'd like to - you
know thank you and thank everybody that
contributed this is it's just a small
number of people whose works I happen to
say in this presentation and I want to
remind everybody it is DNA day on April
25th and so for the entire month of
April they're running a $50 off premise
if you wanted to do your dog now that
was a good time you doing so with that
I'd like to open it up if anybody has
questions I'm not sure how to handle
questions on zoom' so if I don't do it
right I apologize so I think we can have
people if you want to ask the question
go ahead and raise your hand on Zoom or
you can just unmute yourself and start
talking okay well so I have a I have a
question how how many people work at
embark and what about half of them
[Laughter]
we it we're up to and we're so and mark
has offices in Boston and in Ithaca so
the science team is in Ithaca and
comprises about 10 people and then the
Boston office has about 50 people what
kinds of people do you hire them oh yeah
that's that's a good question so a lot
of it is you know software engineering
to maintain these large databases and to
efficiently deliver results and reach
out to relatives and you know like if
you have a relative database and you've
got a quarter million dogs that means
you have a quarter million times a
quarter million relationships right so
there's lots of interesting big data
problems and we also do methods like
imputation so sure we have direct you
know types of 220,000 markers but
actually impute millions of markers so
that we can do the discovery studies and
stuff but we you know obviously we have
a logistics team we have a product team
you know so there's you know lots of
yeah you know things like HR and finance
and boring stuff right and then
scientists and we like people with both
laboratory skills we do our own even
though we outsource the commercial
laboratory stuff to like a CLIA
certified lab that handles you know
millions of samples and you know what I
had has the ability to scale up we still
maintain a research without lab here in
Ithaca so that so there's lots of you
know different skills that we look for
not just on the computational side okay
other questions in veterinarians we hire
veterinarians okay oh okay
hi I'm just wondering um how do you get
um the genotypes of the village dogs so
how do you get the DNA you have someone
going around the world and like yeah so
I should have clarified yeah so we we
actually started that project we had
Cornell's seed money to go and so
this was 2007 and so my brother on his
honeymoon to Africa started st.
employment village dogs in Africa and
and we actually analyzed 350 of the dogs
that he sampled on honeymoon and it was
a pretty cool analysis nobody looked at
village dogs in Africa before we had a
PNAS paper out of it and then we got NSF
funding to expand that to more worldwide
thing and so we worked with local
veterinarians Ryan or I travel to
several of the places we were we were
taking blood draws from the dogs and so
and we because of shipping issues a lot
of times you have to like spin down the
blood in place so Ryan had to like
practice how to explain centrifuge and
Swahili at some of the border crossings
but we but we did that analysis and then
that continued when I started on the
faculty at Cornell and we had
collaborators in Mongolia and I student
go to Nepal and all of these you know
sorts of things to get some of the key
samples for that analysis and and now
for the most part its customers sending
us samples and letting us know where
they got their dog from and we get GPS
coordinates and yeah cool that's amazing
where some people have gotten their dogs
from and it's also amazing the reaction
of some people right like so somebody's
like well you know like you said you
showed a map of my dog and that you know
said you said that my dog was an Indian
village dog but I wanted to know what
breeds for in it it's like well you know
like always have been in India for like
millennia like way before any of these
breeds came right it's and that's what
it is it's not a mixed breed dog and
then other people are like wow you had a
map and it was like right on Delhi and
that's where I got my dog happened to be
a city that we say get it right
um what was the transition from being an
academic scientist to being like a chief
scientific officer of a company what is
that like yeah it was it was pretty
crazy so you know I I was running my lab
and I'm still running my lab but um you
know so starting the company with I mean
the impetus for starting it was that we
had we had gotten funding actually from
a private company to design a dog DNA
test and but it was it was through
Cornell and so does Cornell IP and we
got all built up and and then that
company is like well it's not really in
our wheelhouse this is an we've decided
we're gonna go in a different direction
so you guys do whatever you want to it
all right great and so then we talk to
another company hey use this DNA test we
think the intestine could be a lot
better and we went to several different
companies that we thought would be
interested in doing this but nobody
nobody wanted to kind of take the leap
to do it and so I was kind of like stuck
and but then when my brother was
graduating he's like well you know I
need you help me Adam because I'm about
to graduate with a PhD and I don't want
to be an academic because everybody I
know who's an academic lives in the
circle life it's not about you it's
about me and so we we talked about it
and and then we started to say well
maybe we could maybe there's a business
model idea here maybe instead of trying
to like get another company to do this
test to get the research data we just
start a company and you run the company
and you know I'll provide a scientific
input and and so we went to the Cornell
technology licensing office and sat down
and you know it's a little bit different
of a licensing than they generally do
but they were on board it's been great
we actually get to help Cornell in in
various ways and they certainly have
been a big help you know getting us
started and going and then I so then I
went on sabbatical after I got tenure so
for the last year I've been working for
the company and now this is like my
first week back so you know so I'm back
now
oh I have another question which is how
much does what you're learning in dogs
about diseases translate over to humans
and are we you know is it helping us
understand human health even better oh
yeah absolutely I mean there's there's a
lot of great stories about translational
research that's been done so there's um
you know one of the first Mendelian
diseases and dogs that was identified
was narcolepsy and Doberman Pinschers in
the the gene that that's defective there
wasn't a gene anybody who realized was
involved in in sleep cycle signaling and
so in fact after the dog geneticist
figured it out the human geneticist went
and took a look and it was like 25
percent of cases of narcolepsy that they
had no explanation for it were due to
defects in that gene another instance
Deschenes muscular dystrophy so dogs
also have a defect in the same gene so
there's a colony of dogs that they raise
so they can do to change muscular
dystrophy studies and so they testing
different drugs and therapeutics and
stuff like that but genetically one of
the interesting things to come out of
that was that in that colony a dog
tested for it should have the disease
but didn't have the severe phenotype at
all it was so mild it wasn't even
noticeable like dogs seemed normal and
they thought that was odd I thought
there must have been something in the
upbringing of this dog or you know it's
really kind of an outlier we don't know
what's going on and they just kind of
chalked it up to randomness but
fortunately the colony wasn't run that
well and the dog escaped and wound up
hiring three litters and several of the
dogs pups also tested at risk but didn't
have the Deschenes phenotype and so then
they started doing genetic testing and
so then they found this compensatory
mutation in a completely different
chromosome that led to up regulation of
this jagged gene and so that seems to be
what's protecting them from the severe
phenotype so now you've had this new
drug target that you can start to look
at to see if you can design something
that will up regulate and is that going
to help in the human okay so there's a
lot of the time you know most of the
diseases and
let's have human equivalents and many
cases it's the same gene in some cases
the same amino acid that's being mutated
that's that's leading to the disease so
there's lots of opportunities for
translational medicine that way what
we'd like to do is I mean I think dogs
are a great model for aging research for
cancer research but we just need to know
more about the genetics of it to really
to really accelerate that kind of
translational research yeah sounds like
you're getting there it's gonna be
really exciting yeah yeah definitely and
in the dog genome got published in 2005
so is that was the first year I started
my post yeah Ciara graduated my PhD so
it was sort of the right time to get
into the field any other questions
Francis um so you said that there's a
gene in dogs that's associated with
compulsive behavior that's that's also
involved in obsessive compulsive
disorder in humans yeah I'm wondering
what gee I mean what gene is that are
like how how strongly is it correlated
with obsessive compulsive disorder in
humans I'm not familiar enough with
human literature to go out on a limb and
say I mean obviously it's obsessive
compulsive disorder is not a Mendelian
trait in people it's it's got more
complicated genetics but it's definitely
true that there are different genetic
bases and and depending on whether or
not you have certain genetic defects
that are that are predisposing for it
you might respond better to certain
classes of drugs yeah um and so that's
that's kind of why it's interesting
because it's also been suggested oh
maybe we should treat the dogs with some
of these same drugs that we used for for
some of the people yeah cuz I've heard
of draw dogs getting antidepressants and
stuff yeah yeah and then we still own I
mean I don't know enough about the
genetics behind the temperament I don't
I don't know how successful
anti-depression medication and dogs are
but you know it doesn't surprise me that
many of the medicines work the saying
you just have to be careful because you
know again things that humans can
tolerate or can be toxic to dogs and so
you don't want to go too far without
doing the appropriate
yeah okay if there's no further
questions thank you for a completely
awesome talk it was really ok sorry I'm
very person but yeah maybe we should
like I'm gonna you all and then we'll
give you give you around of across that
didn't work quite as well as I hoped but
is really there thank you so much this
has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu